[Music]
now more than ever
buyers are turning to cloud marketplaces
to fulfill their procurement needs
as marketplaces are poised to capture a
significant percentage of the 230
billion dollar
sas and cloud software market in 2021
learn how you can purchase multiple
solution types
sas vms containers data sets and apis on
google cloud marketplace
that are vetted by google cloud to cover
your enterprise's it needs
all of this with a single bill and the
ease of deployment you've never seen
before
google cloud marketplace is a modern
procurement platform
offering a diverse selection of security
database networking solutions
and more this video will walk you
through how google cloud marketplace
improves your it solution buying
experience and empowers your procurement
team to procure and fulfill
fast with a single bill from google the
marketplace has both google cloud
products
and partner solutions to ensure you can
find exactly what you need
[Music]
let's begin by navigating to the
marketplace there are three ways to do
this
if you're not logged in to the google
cloud console you can access the
marketplace homepage by typing in
cloud.google.com marketplace
or just searching for google cloud
marketplace
if you are in your console you'll see
the marketplace in the left navigation
bar
one final way to access the marketplace
is via what's called a cameo
cameos show the marketplace in the
context of your current console location
offering a marketplace experience that
is personalized to your needs
once you reach the marketplace homepage
browse anonymously
or if you're interested in purchasing or
seeing what you have deployed
log in using your google credentials if
you know what you're looking for the
search bar is in the center of the page
or you can browse shelves that showcase
the different solutions available
we keep these shelves fresh for instance
we were the first marketplace to add a
coven 19 data set
the other shelves here feature commonly
searched for solution areas
such as vms gcp services sas
os dev stacks etc on the left side
you'll see filters
these include different types of
products and categories as well as
industries which are new and we're
constantly adding more to help you
easily
find the right solutions google cloud
products can be found
under the google cloud platform filter
let's say you want to browse virtual
machines begin by clicking virtual
machines to see the vm solutions we have
before filtering further
let's say we want to look for load
balancing ubuntu
from here you can explore a solution in
more detail
we're going to go ahead and click on the
second one here
nginx plus basic ubuntu 18.04
the right column provides the technical
specs such as what the solution runs
on and its type further down the
overview page there's more information
about the solution and company
a pricing table tutorials and
documentation training and support
and the terms of service many vm
solutions have free trials which are
listed at the top
like this one says 30 day trial
[Music]
available
let's take a look at a sas solution next
search for netapp and let autocomplete
suggest
netapp cloud volume service click on the
first option here
as with the vm solution this page
outlines technical specs and further
down the overview page
there's more information about the
solution and company
a pricing table tutorials and
documentation
training and support and the terms of
service
let's go ahead and hit purchase note
that only users that are billing admins
and at least a project viewer will be
able to do this
once you have clicked purchase you can
select a plan preferred usage fees and
specs
and more on the right side there's a
pricing slider to help you more
accurately calculate the overall cost
at the bottom are the terms of service
we're looking at building custom user
license agreements directly within the
marketplace
but for now you'll see the terms of the
partner and gcp
when you hit subscribe your order will
go to the vendor for approval
next we're going to look at what we call
private offers
we know that many developers purchase
pay as you go solutions to try them out
and then
if the trial goes well they will want to
purchase the solution
with private offers you can get
negotiated prices from the partner via
the marketplace
from the details page click contact to
get in touch with the partners to start
negotiating an offer
once the price is negotiated the partner
simply needs to access their marketplace
partner portal
and fill in the relevant details to
create your discount
when this is saved a url will be
generated which the vendor will email to
you
to do this the customer will need to
have billing admin rights and at least
be a viewer on the project
one additional benefit is that these
purchases count towards your google
cloud commit drawdown
we're continuously gathering feedback
and improving the flow
[Music]
now if you go back to the marketplace
homepage click on your solutions to view
information about everything that you've
purchased this page shows you what you
need to activate
what's failed what's expired what's
currently running
and more we're revamping this page to
include order management related tasks
here as well
if you click on the hamburger menu on
the top left and hit billing
you'll see all the info about how you're
being billed
you can see how much you're spending
every month and what you're forecasted
to spend this month
if you click view report you can drill
down further by project
or even change to group by sku for a
deeper understanding of billing cost
we also provide the option to add
solutions to a private catalog
an enterprise governance tool that
enables admins to take content from
marketplace
the private catalog provides a tool for
admins to add pre-approved solutions
that have been vetted
and verified and follow their internal
governance and compliance policies
these solutions can come from the
marketplace or can be internally created
solutions
enterprise customers then have a single
place to discover approved solutions
that they can deploy
knowing the solutions have been approved
and verified by their cloud admin
here you can see an example of a private
catalog which looks and feels like the
marketplace
ready to get going don't forget to
leverage the 300
credit that google cloud currently
offers to get started
begin by exploring more than 2 000
solutions available
on google cloud marketplace today